they brought out a vegan sausage roll
and everyone went mental there's no anus
in this hello I'm Ricky Gervais is and
this is lad Bible back in time line
there we go
what was my first Instagram pic I I have
no idea
should we see I mean yeah brilliant
excellent I am an Instagram it's just
like the Kardashians what was the photo
that went with his caption when in
Copenhagen that's me as a mermaid do you
know what Jane took that obviously cuz
usually I do my own bar selfies but it
took ages of course the costume was way
too small for me but it's basically
meant for a little girl I assume right
what describes PC gone man it's
obviously me taking the piss out of an
outrage yeah I heard that staff at
Gregg's are holding fat people down and
forcing them to eat lettuce so this is
they brought out a vegan sausage roll
and everyone went mental like they had
to eat it like it was compulsory I want
the meat one No you've got the pastry
you like anyways I mean no real meat in
the meat 101 bit weird just found this
in my bellybutton I've done a few of
these and it's usually like like a baby
creature I've always wanted an hour
Johnny not just one on your desk holding
your pencil who am i standing beside in
this photo David Bowie
my word what a man what a date amazing
I invited him to do extras he did I sent
him the lyrics for the song that he did
and then I called him up and I said give
you some what retro like life on Mars
I just went yeah I'm knock off a quick
in life on Mars for you
warm water works too Kate Beckinsale is
the latest celebrity to try treatment
which uses a serum derived from babies
circumcised penises I must put these out
of my head
once I've tweeted oh you know I mean
like an exercise wait but then I try and
forget the world we live in I mean oh
god I mean why are we circumcised in
babies anyway how can we have enough
baby foreskins to go into business the
American version of The Office is better
than the UK version how does that make
you feel rich really yeah
who was i posing with in this photo
Constantine the Frog no Kermit
now it's Constantine I think it's Connor
on the order its Constantine yeah see
you fell for his brilliant disguise
Constantine the evil Russian frog
pretending to be
yeah it's neezy mistake guys don't be
embarrassed I'm still a male the people
I just think it's something like the
people are awful so cocky too easy to
idiots in New York getting coffee again
whoo I'm over with in this photo Jerry
Seinfeld a big red rolls-royce go around
New York with the top down and me and
Jerry Seinfeld I mean that's asking for
trouble
dear Pontifex despite changing the genre
of TV sitcom and going on to break
referencing podcasting Award nominations
of stand-up comedy around the world
the Queen has once again shat on my
knight oh do I ask him for a sainthood
yes again that can reply what is my most
favorite tweet of all time oh my most
favorited what is my most favorited
tweet of all time I see so which one got
the most favourites
I'd guess anatomy animal cruelty one a
freedom of speech is it is that is it
the I've come up with so many corkers I
can't narrow it down but I can't
remember I go on a solo if you don't
believe in free speech for people who
hate fear and disagree with then you
don't believe in free speech ah 65
thousand likes see that makes me think
there's hope
[Music]